tout s'est passé très vite si vite
il m'a attrapé par le col déchirant mon
collier et il m'a fait tomber au sol
j'ai atterri sur la gamelle du chien qui
s'est brisé sur mon dos les morceaux
m'ont coupé à l'aide je suis resté là à
un moment et tout dit puis je me suis
levé et je lui ai demandé de sortir
commande viens frappe-moi tu te
sentirais mieux si tu me frapper te
faire quoi allez on avait l'habitude de
se battre ça fait sentir mieux pourquoi
vous vous battiez
vous savez on était des enfants
on se bagarre pour des choses futiles
la différence ce jour-là était le niveau
de colère et de frustration
j'ai parlé de ce que j'avais en moi
pendant tout ce temps
et j'ai vu cette colère en lui
et je peux garantir aujourd'hui que si
je ne faisais pas de thérapie
pour apprendre à gérer la colère et la
frustration je leur ai frappé en retour
sur à 100%
[Applaudissements]
. il était très très fort s'il a la
vidéo c'est là quand il parle de la
bagarre quand William il a mis dans la
gamelle que l'on a effacé
[Rires]
à force de voir sur le fil d'actualité
en permanence toutes ces actualités nos
herbes j'arrive sur la famille royale je
me suis couché oui c'est vrai dormir
je t'ai couché quoi tu as dormi cet
aprèm oui j'ai dormi
royale donc voir tout ça ça me chagrine
[Rires]
sur la royauté des rêves sur la royauté
[Musique]
[Rires]
tu as vu l'interview là donc en effet
vous avez on a d'autres extraits à
partir de 23 ans donc diffuse c'est
interview qui a été diffusé hier sur iti
qui est la principale chaîne privée
anglaise
tout à l'heure en effet flop finition
qu'ils ont diffusé sur
[Musique]
elle en revanche en Amérique alors
qu'est-ce que ça va être l'interview de
ce soir elle va durer une heure et
pendant une heure et bien on va avoir un
règlement de compte énorme en règlement
de compte dans lequel c'est une campagne
de promotions
c'est un peu moins fort que ce que l'on
aurait pu croire parce que vous savez
depuis l'Espagne a levé l'embargo et
l'Espagne a déjà commencé à vendre avec
l'Espagne
toutes les informations nous sont déjà
livrés également déjà l'intégralité de
ce des horreurs alors on arrive on a un
deuxième extrait Harry pourra-t-il faire
la paix avec sa famille selon Harry il y
a trop de non-dits regardez
il n'y a pas de paix sans vérité ma
famille et moi il s'agit de reconnaître
nos erreurs
la réconciliation dépend de nous mais
tout le reste les médias doivent rester
en dehors de ça
le silence ne permet que les abus
oui
arranger les choses
c'est sincèrement ce que je pense
[Applaudissements]
elle prend les gens pour les cons
c'est devenu un candidat de téléréalité
en fait chaque jour il balance une
saloperie sur sa famille donc un coup
c'est sur Netflix
ces journées est-ce qu'il travaille ou
il fait que il donne des conseils il est
consultant pour une grosse boîte
américaine mais en effet elle a acheté
des parcs dans une consultation
ils ont voulu quitter la famille royale
et non dans le fond jamais été à ce
point présent on ne cesse de les voir
pour raconter systématiquement des
horreurs et moi ce qui me fait très peur
c'est qui c'est que il se prend il s'en
prend à une institution qui réduite au
silence qui est obligé de se taire on
sait très bien que le palais de
Buckingham communique très peu alors que
eux ils déballent tout en permanence à
un moment donné dans le livre il nous
parle quand même de ses testicules là
le jour du de de William et de Kate et
le pire de toute sa vie parce que il a
pénétré sous les fuites de Messenger
alors qu'il avait des testicules gelées
puisqu'il refroidi d'une escapade dans
le pot au micro-ondes
voilà donc ça c'est un peu anecdotique
on s'en fout un peu mais là où ça
devient terrible c'est que c'est il
passe vraiment l'ensemble de la firme de
la famille royale ou karcher à propos de
Camilla par exemple et on sait très bien
que Kamina et l'élément non négociable
pour Charles adore Camila et bien il va
nous dire que Camilla à un moment donné
elle a dû refaire son image auprès de la
presse elle était voilà on demande une
image un peu plus positive et il n'a pas
été mis à n'a pas hésité à décrocher son
téléphone elle-même c'est ce qu'il nous
dit pour balancer des informations
concernant Harry et Mégane alors à la
presta bleu regardez dernière extrait
que nous a donné TF1 ce sera ce soir sur
TF1 regarder cet extrait
[Rires]
les conversations privées dans son livre
selon lui sa famille a fait bien pire
regardez il défonce encore la famille ça
t'as rien fait toi j'ai dormi moi
regarde
vous parlez de discussion privée mais
vous avez dit usine quantité énorme de
conversation privée qui sont apparus
dans la presse et votre frère se dit
Harry comment tu peux faire ça après
tout ce qu'on a traversé
il dit aussi probablement d'autres
choses mais vous savez sur les dernières
années
sur les six dernières années
le niveau des déclarations des autres
membres de la famille
pour moi ils ont écrit l'équivalent d'un
nombre incalculable de livres des
millions de mots
très dur crash sur moi ma femme à tel
point que j'ai dû quitter mon pays
un petit peu méchant mais les
journalistes anglais les disent de Harry
que malheureusement il n'a pas de
cerveau de son père entendait qu'il est
un petit peu idiot et malheureusement il
a été sous emprise de Mégane qui elle
est très intelligent même les très
méchants disaient malheureusement il a
le cerveau de sa mère pardon mais c'est
ce qu'il disait
voilà et il n'est pas c'est pas le plus
malin il a été sous emprise de Mégane
qui est très intelligente c'est tout ce
qu'il dit et c'est vrai et aujourd'hui
ce gamin déballe tout et cette monarchie
qui était la plus vieille d'Europe et la
plus belle tu as raison aujourd'hui
c'est les Anges de la téléréalité et
vraiment Mégane ça a été ça a été
hamburger au pays de de Britanniques et
ça a été une catastrophe et voilà le
résultat hamburger au pays c'est comme
ça que tu t'y
retrouveraise elle a voulu que
l'Angleterre se fasse ses règles
américaines
et je dois dire que je suis complètement
changé depuis le livre depuis la série
je suis devenu team Harry il est idiot
mais en fait on s'en fout pourquoi tu
les fais un procès en intelligence en
fait c'est absurde en fait en quoi toi
tu vas décerner des points de QI
d'intelligence et tout ça moi je le
trouve sincère je trouve ça
psychologiquement maltraitée par la
royauté elle a été maltraitée ils ont
été harcelés par la presse vous êtes en
Angleterre donc excusez-moi et alors
vous dites oui mais il fait ça pour
avoir de l'oseille mais aujourd'hui il a
plus l'argent par exemple des
contribuables anglais et donc il a
raison d'avoir de l'argent de qui lui
donne de l'argent j'ai la vérité
je trouve vraiment que cette expérience
c'est quand même une comédie
extraordinaire et et franchement c'est
drôle moi je m'éclate
10 millions 10 millions
c'est un mauvais procès qu'on lui fait
Harry on le critiquant parce que
franchement et pour vous répondre sur la
médiatisation tout son livre c'est de
dire les paparazzis ont tué ma mère
d'ailleurs il a refait le trajet sur le
pont de l'Alma c'est voilà c'est de dire
on a été harcelé en permanence donc
c'est la médiatisation pour lui ça a tué
son esprit d'enfant ça a tué sa mère et
les journaux anglais il peut pas les
supporter
à son corps défendant il a été meurtri
par ça
de la faute de Charles parce qu'il n'a
pas été suffisamment présenté
parce que elle met le grappa sur Harry
sur William c'est de la faute de William
parce qu'il est brutal et violent c'est
tout le temps la faute de quelqu'un
même dans le livre qu'il a dû attendre
23 ans pour se faire était bel et bien
morte qu'est-ce qu'il dit il a été
convaincu jusqu'à tes 23 ans
qu'elle était partie il voyait des
signes de la présence de sagesse
est-ce que tu t'en fous total comme moi
non ça m'intéresse ouais mais je
comprends pas qu'il l'aime pas en fait
juste parce qu'il ose dire la
vérités
il a le droit de dire ce qui se passe
chez lui mademoiselle ils ont été
touchés par du racisme ou pas
dans le livre les documents et dans les
livres et il dit que il a peut-être été
un peu trop fort par rapport au racisme
mais c'est tout le temps comme ça
je trouve que le jugement de dire il est
fou il est pas stable il est encore sa
mère était vivant lorsqu'elle était
morte on peut pas le juger enfin je veux
dire tu te rends compte qu'il a quand
même dit il a dit j'ai tué 25 talibans
j'en suis fier aujourd'hui il est même
menacé quasiment il est même menacé
l'Angleterre est menacé il a dit que
j'étais 25 quand tu tires la
mitrailleuse mais au-delà de ça il est
fier d'avoir tué 25 calibres et
aujourd'hui c'est la chance
il y a une amie qui nous dit Harry
défense sa mère oui et son frère bien
sûr son père la bagarre ira jusqu'au
bout est-ce que tu en penses toi
jusqu'au bout windsurde on va faire un
pitoyable je suis convaincu ce n'est pas
encore fini et alors là si je peux dire
une place
le livre de c'est ça c'est vraiment
dommage se termine mais de façon Grenade
où il dit que lui dans le fond il ne
sait pas vraiment si il insistera au
couronnement de Charles le 6 mai
prochain mais que il tend la main et que
c'est à eux au Windsor de revenir vers
lui mais il est fou il est fou il est
fou
il est fou
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]